it's the immediacy the violence it's the
quickest way to a plot twist what are we
talking about the rocks
muck no we are talking about explosions
they are freaking everywhere in video
games and if you saw the new Jessica
three trailer you'd be forgiven for
thinking that the main character wasn't
Rico but some huge fireball creature
that destroys island nations
construction sites like nobody's
business
explosions are so prevalent in video
games right so we'll just cause threes
even stand a chance of being memorable
well let's hope it has some that are
just as sweet as the ones on our list of
the best explosions and video games
so what is the criteria check it out an
in-game explosion is just a collection
of sound design software engineering
physics art and the best takeaway one of
those things and everything falls apart
so here's a list of games we think
excels at bringing all those things
together to make fake explosions we're
talking gameplay ones real time not
cutscene ones ones that are not simply
seen and heard about leaving the player
ready for more
number five half-life 2 for a game over
ten years old the quick and dense sound
design and the mess of props and dudes
flying around is still so good it's
timeless no game has nailed the feeling
lots of energy being released rapidly
way half of two heads
they aren't over-the-top I can adjust
Cosway but sometimes isn't the size the
cap it's the distance you get off a
combine rag doll
Oh Mary package for you no problem
number four crisis crisis one explosion
are still really top-notch there are
these bright champagne color murder
balls that shower the environment with
sparks the way the foilage and buildings
react to their fury makes them feel so
believable
it's like watching real video footage of
something going up not all them in that
game are great them like the c-4 pepper
that was not that good number three Just
Cause two Just Cause twos explosive
effects lay on the dark smoke nice and
thick add-ins and chunky sound effects
and these bad boys are a treat for your
senses but the real reason this game
made the cut is because of a sweet mod
that adds a little kid to the trigger
and explosive
number two red faction guerrilla red
faction guerrilla is a game about
destroying stuff so the explosions just
tear apart buildings with a fidelity you
just don't get to see that often yeah
for this reason the geomod engine is
just so fun to set bombs off in it's
kind of like a science project
number one grand theft auto 5 they are
so unique and expressive and they cause
the best chain reactions just watch
all right hold up here I mean interrupt
for a second now when we play these back
in the editor in slow-mo they lose their
believability we can start to see
through the individual elements that are
playing back designed to fool us into
thinking we were seeing something more
than just JPEGs being triggered on the
screen
it's that delicate balance that I was
talking about before the takeaway is
there's still tons of room for
improvement healing for twos artists
animated their weapons at over 200
frames per second for greater fidelity
and smoothness when the game kicks in to
its slo-mo Zed time I can imagine a
world where this process starts
trickling down to things such as
explosion effects a whole new world will
start to come alive in these super high
fidelity high frame rate slow-mo
explosions in a whole new way so that is
do we forget some do we leave anything
off that you guys think is particularly
awesome let us know see you next time
battery is working in this thing or
something